welcome to the first top 5 of 2019 I'm
Walter benezia I'm Heather Ruth and I'm
Ayano Abe we're kicking off the new year
with a countdown on the Caped Crusader
himself this year marks the 80th
anniversary of Batman's first appearance
in Detective Comics way back in 1939
from comics to movies to TV shows the
Dark Knight has had a wide variety of
interpretations the actors that have
brought Batman to life on the big and
small screens have helped us to find the
character going as far back as 1943
actors have been portraying Gotham's
resident vigilante as different writers
and artists have tweaked him over the
decades how we saw him played on screen
has evolved whether we see their faces
in live-action films or just hear their
voices and animated projects plenty of
actors have taken their best shot at
being the best Batman and Bruce Wayne
they can be but which of these thespians
come to mind immediately when we think
of the world's greatest detective which
of them are so synonymous with the
character that it has shaped their
careers these are the top five best
Batman actors number five
then I got him killed my partner my
soldier my fault I own that I'll carry
that like everything else probably the
least well-known Batman on our list
Bruce Greenwood should not be left out
of this conversation
he has discreetly amassed quite the
legacy for himself
voicing Batman in several high-profile
animated endeavors Greenwood voices
Batman in the critically acclaimed Young
Justice series and while he doesn't
always have a big part in that show when
he shows up he brings the gravitas of
Batman with him Robin needed to help
bring the men who murdered his family to
justice so he could turn out like you so
that he wouldn't last year's animated
film Batman Gotham by Gaslight also
featured his vocal talents the movie is
based off the Elseworlds story from 1989
but took several liberties with the
material and produced a pretty decent
entry in DC's animated catalog Greenwood
plays a Batman of the Victorian era
hunting down Jack the Ripper I ran into
your Ripper
earlier this evening approximately 6
foot 3 inches 250 pounds left-handed
good fighter trained not just a brawler
the main reason he fits onto our list
though is the 2010 animated film Batman
under the Red Hood a couple years ago I
ranked it as the best Batman animated
movie and I still hold that to be true
today all the emotion and nuance in that
story is appropriately reflected in his
performance the possible resurrection of
Jason Todd the second Robin who was
murdered by the Joker has Batman out of
sorts he reminisces on happier times
with his young sidekick while a new
version of the villainous Red Hood is
distributing lethal justice on the
streets of Gotham
unreal
[Music]
we go beneath the cowl in this
performance and get to the root of how
Bruce truly feels about his failure to
save Jason his relationship with the
Joker is also explored any fascinating
scene all I've ever wanted to do is kill
him a day doesn't go by when I don't
think about subjecting him to every
horrendous torture he's dealt out to
others and then end him
oh so you do think about me while many
might look past Greenwoods contributions
to the Batman legacy he is an important
piece of the puzzle who often does not
get the recognition he deserves the
level of quality he brings to his vocal
presentation creates one of the best
portrayal of any of his peers check out
the projects he's voiced Batman in and
see for yourself number four
[Music]
someday she just can't get rid of a bomb
the name Adam West has become synonymous
with Batman for a whole generation of
people Batman premiered on television in
1966 with a movie released that same
year Adam West played the titular
character as well as his alter-ego Bruce
Wayne it's rumored that one of the
reasons West was cast was because he was
one of the only people who could read
the lines sincerely with a straight face
West's interpretation of the character
is very unusual from what one would
expect when thinking of Batman he was
campy colorful and hammy earning the
nickname bright Knight but this is what
made the show and the performance great
it was meant to be a comedy directed at
children and young adults and the show
hit and embraced that market with
tongue-in-cheek comedy West had amazing
chemistry with his sidekick Robin played
by Burt Ward they worked so well
together it even started some
interesting rumors about Batman and
Robin Batman went on to be one of the
most popular shows of the mid 60s
thousands of people grew up watching
Adam West as the Caped Crusader he
became an icon long after the series and
movie ended Adam West was typecast
because of the role however he later
embraced the infamy and returned many
times to the role of Batman in a variety
of shows and media including one of my
favorite episodes of Batman the Animated
Series so love it or hate it Adam West
and his interpretation of the character
will live on as one of the most popular
and iconic versions number three I want
you to tell all your friends about me
I'm Batman following Adam West's
portrayal as Batman was a golden
opportunity to shift towards the darker
comic-book depiction until this point
all we had on screen was well you watch
number four in Tim Burton's Batman the
Caped Crusader was given the inevitable
darker twist the muted color palette and
moody lighting was quite the shift going
head-to-head with his pivotal antagonist
was the right decision to show off some
acting chops as well Keaton's Batman was
able to stand out and scenes with Jack
Nicholson's Joker that alone is an
impressive feat and in Batman Returns
his on-screen chemistry with Michelle
Pfeiffer as Catwoman was palpable he
brought something even more special as
Bruce Wayne that no other actor really
has since he needs the bat more than
Gotham does Keaton's Bruce barely takes
care of himself while Batman seems to
lay dormant in the daylight hours Master
Wayne uses sarcasm as a wall while
Keaton's natural energy hints of a
serious punch just below the surface and
although he's not the roided-out brick
wall we've come to expect Keaton had the
physicality one could hope for the
midnight vigilante top 5 has covered his
performance as well as Batman Returns
before but it was truly worth revisiting
by originating the more brooding bat
Keaton paved the way for other
interpretations of Batman number 2
[Music]
Christian Bale is the actor who has
played Batman on the big screen for the
longest amount of time he had years to
perfect the role Bale first donned the
cowl and cape in 2005 and Batman Begins
Bale continued to play the character for
two more movies to complete the Dark
Knight trilogy Bale has been known
throughout his career to be a dedicated
and intense method actor this trilogy is
no exception he threw himself into the
role bulking up reading comics learning
martial arts in order to perform stunts
Bale brought an unmatched intensity to
Batman playing that side of the
character as and I quote an absolute
sincere creature he makes it feel like
Batman is something primal that Bruce
Wayne struggles to contain and control
although I will admit that Batman voice
does border on comical they must have
friends as Bruce Wayne Bale plays a
perfect mix of conceited aloof confident
yet witty fitting of a billionaire
playboy Bale was a piece of the puzzle
that came together to make the Dark
Knight trilogy amazing changing
landscape of modern superhero movies his
performance is unforgettable
[Music]
and the number one best Batman actor is
engines I am the night
[Music]
probably the most obvious number one of
any top five that we've ever done but
that doesn't make it any less true so
much has been said about Kevin Conroy
Batman over the years that you likely
already know why he's in our top spot
but just to add our own praises unto the
greatest Batman his is the only voice I
hear when i'm reading the caped
crusaders dialog and a comic when I
think of Batman's voice it's Conroy's
that comes to mind naturally his heavy
deep approach to the character was a hit
from the beginning thoughtful and
soft-spoken in quiet moments but
appropriately terrifying in others also
in the earlier seasons of the animated
series his Bruce Wayne was very
different playing up the playboy nice
guy heir to the Wayne family fortune
created a nice contrast thanks for the
handkerchief Arthur you know where you
can stick it since then his Batman and
Bruce voices have become almost the same
but we know he can change it up if he
ever feels the need to on the other end
of the spectrum he does a great aged
Bruce in Batman Beyond there is a
noticeable shift in his pitch and
gruffer slower cadence to his speaking
it's what I want Bruce stupid kid you
don't know what you want no never did
the guy can do it all and he's not only
well-known to those who grew up watching
Batman the Animated Series sure that
show has endured as one of the best
animated series of all time but he's
still voicing The Dark Knight and a lot
of projects more modern animated films
and shows like Batman and Harley Quinn
and Justice League action have kept him
in the spotlight but he might be most
well known to younger fans from his work
in the Arkham Asylum and injustice video
games with a recently announced Justice
League versus the final 5 featuring
Conroy once again donning the proverbial
cape and cowl there's no end in sight
and I for one would love to hear him
voice Batman as long as he wants we want
to hear what you guys think who's your
favorite Batman actor what do you want
to see us cover next on the show leave a
comment and let us know to keep in touch
you could like my Facebook page or
follow along on Twitter you can find me
on Facebook Twitter Instagram or
subscribe to my animated movie review
series right here on YouTube and you can
find me on Twitter Instagram or Twitter
I stream on Wednesday nights or catch
you back here next week with a brand new
episode top five one does not simply
tease the next episode of top 5 without
giving any clues mmm second breakfast
elevenses
[Music]
[Applause]
you